British astronaut Tim Peake has
announced that he will be going back
into space for a second time delighted
to say he joins us now from Steven itch
Tim Peake good afternoon to you thanks
it's in the gift isn't it at the
European Space Agency this they will
decide when but you'll go back what on a
soyuz as you did last time how will it
work well yes the announcement was made
this morning really for my whole class
of 2009 that the extension of the
international space station program to
2024 will enable all of us to have the
opportunity for a second mission back to
the space station the timings of that
mission is yet to be determined by the
European Space Agency okay we saw you
this morning at the Science Museum
poring over the Soyuz capsule you went
up in and came back to the Kazakh steppe
on still singed from some of the
re-entry temperatures which must have
been absolutely colossal what comes
across more than anything when you look
back at those pictures of you going up
giving that wonderful thumbs up perfect
illustration of British pluck is the
sense of claustrophobia it we right in
taking that away from the sense of what
it was like did you feel terribly
claustrophobic yeah absolutely it's
something that a lot of people commented
to me about this morning when they saw
the capsule was how small it looks and
it is I mean really that's part of the
design is is when you're bringing
something back through the Earth's
atmosphere the smaller it is the easier
it is to engineer so it's a small
capsule is a very tight space and in
fact when it's packed up with a cargo
that we bring back from the space
station it's even smaller inside so
anybody who suffer from claustrophobia
certainly wouldn't do very well inside
the Soyuz I remember listening to an
interview I think it was with the late
John Glenn talking about coming back and
there was a flashing warning light
indicating that with the perhaps the
heat shield was loosed and he said he
became super sensitive to any warming in
the rear quarters did you is something I
was very surprised that I mean it sounds
strange it you know you you know that
you're going to experience very hot
temperatures when you come back through
the Earth's atmosphere and the capsule
it has to withstand 1600 degrees Celsius
but inside the capsule of course it's
very very hot and that all three of us
were absolutely drained
in sweat when we were dragged out of the
capsule drenched in sweat you couldn't
really walk as well the whole the whole
weight and the experience really took
its toll on you but do you have any idea
when you're going to be going back and
what are you going to be doing because
the last time you carried out around 200
250 experiments and you also kept
yourself entertained Carnaby do you have
any idea what you're going to be doing
going heading back to space ii darling
with the space station program the great
thing about that is that the science is
a rolling evolution and the experiments
continue to go up there what's really
exciting is since I've landed in fact
we've started DNA sequencing on board
the space station we're studying more
genetics more pharmaceutical companies
are being involved in the medical
research that we're doing so the science
program just continues to evolve and the
astronauts really whenever they go to
the space station they slot in to that
to that science program and you'll be
trained up on those experiments near at
the time so that's the job of any
astronaut is to be able to perform those
scientific experiments and also maintain
the space station which may require for
example a spacewalk or using the robotic
arm for resupply vehicles to mark my
children all their enormous families of
yours partly because you're the first
Briton to walk in space but also because
we live quite close to middle wallop the
Army Air Corps where you used to fly
from in your what Army Air Corps days I
suppose how do you put a metric how do
you measure that sense of inspiration I
mean quite clearly you know for many
people not least my children you're a
household name but what's the degree how
can you demonstrate how you have
inspired generation of young people who
perhaps might not have been as
interested in science and space as they
have been because of you I think one of
the most wonderful things for me
personally since landing has been going
on the post-flight tour having the
opportunity to visit schools
universities and have school conferences
as well and to really see the impact
that mission Principia made I know that
during the mission we reached out to
over a million school students and even
more since then and these educational
programs are continuing to run which is
incredible that's one of the great
things about it and I'm stood here at
the moment at Airbus and Stevenage in
the Mars yard where today we're opening
a stem center called discovery space and
and this is
an example of how space is continuing to
inspire a younger generation to get
involved in science and engineering and
technology and that's going to be
important not only because there are
genuinely rewarding and exciting careers
to have in that area but also we have a
skill shortage that we need to address
in the UK so trying to encourage
students at a younger age to get
involved in STEM subjects is very
important and just delighted that
Principia was able to do that and what
was recovery like when you when you
landed back on earth and your body
recovering to the toll being in space
for six months took on you your mind
your body what was that like for you and
how excited are you to spend more time
in space you're right I mean it does
take a huge toll on your body being in
space for six months but that's one of
the remarkable things one of the things
that we study is not just how quickly
the body adapts to living in space but
how quickly the body adapts to coming
back into a gravity environment and it
only took about three weeks before I
felt actually very comfortable my
balance had retained regained normality
I felt strong I felt fit enough I was
running but it actually took two it took
about six months before my muscles and
my bone density really made a decent
recovery and of course every astronaut
accepts that when you go into space
you're going to put your body through
this punishing regime but that's that's
something that we all we all sign up to
and actually the rewards of spaceflight
in terms of the science that we're
involved in in terms of view of planet
Earth and the inspirational the factor
that we can have far outweigh the
negative negative sides term status
everybody got time for one more question
I know we all to editorially ask you
about why it is you're a Martian
landscape in Stevenage but I'm going to
ignore that question because I'm really
keen to ask you instead and we I was on
presenting a year ago when you when you
had the launch and remember thinking as
everybody else must have thought
vicariously as you gave that thumbs up
in the capsule you know I think the
phrase we used at the time was that your
honor it was like going to space on a
gigantic firework that at any moment
could do something unpredictable how did
you keep yourself calm do you know that
the training is the one thing that
enables us to keep calm in those
situations we had done that launch
sequence hundreds of times in the
simulators in Star City in Russia
covering any eventualities that could
have possibly have come on the trailer
Jim well the one thing the simulator
can't give you of course the simulator
can't give you that the sounds and the
smells and the acceleration and
everything so so that's very different
inside the capsule but other than that
it's your training is is what really
keeps you calm because you're empowered
with the knowledge that if something
goes wrong at least you know what to do
you've got options and the Soyuz
spacecraft is is a great vehicle to go
into space in because it does have you
do have options at every stage during
the launch sequence if something goes
wrong well he's an all-round British
hero absolutely imperturbable he's on
thousands of meter interviews I'm sure
but he still as fresh as a daisy tim
peake thanks ever so much and good
looking to you really good good luck
thank you very much